riddle me this
who's afraid of the big black welcome
back everyone it's Charlie this is gonna
be my video for the Batman movie they
finally confirmed who the Riddler is and
who's gonna be playing there Selina Kyle
Catwoman
so if you're new to the channel we're
doing a new DC giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
your favorite version of the Riddler and
Catwoman on the video I'll explain
what's going on with the Riddler first
then I'll talk about what's going on
with Catwoman
so the Riddler was just confirmed as
Paul day know he's gonna be playing the
Edward gnashed and version of the
Riddler not Edward nygma if you're not a
big comic book reader Edward Nash ttan
is just the original name that the
Riddler went by in the classic comics
when he was originally created later
writers that came on the title then gave
him the Edward nygma name enigma as an
enigma so this is just Matt Reeves going
back to the classic material which gives
you an idea for how he's treating a lot
of the other Batman characters in his
franchise going for all the deep cuts if
you don't know who Paul Dano is probably
some of his best performances are in
Paul Thomas Anderson's there will be
blood gigantic and prisoners if you ever
wanted to see what the Hugh Jackman
version of Batman might feel like while
he's interrogating the Riddler here's a
clip from that fun fact that movie also
stars Jake Gyllenhaal who for a brief
period was rumoured to potentially be
the next version of the Batman he's even
interrogating Paul Danos character
during this give you all kinds of dark
night vibes a lot of you heard the news
a couple weeks ago when Jonah Hill was
actually rumored to be locking the role
down he was either going to be playing
the Riddler or the penguin the trades
are reporting that he dropped out of the
running because he was asking for too
much money in the studio didn't one
another Batman 1989 situation with Jack
Nicholson's Joker making vastly greater
sums of money than the person playing
the title character Batman Michael
Keaton nowadays you don't necessarily
need big celebrities to sell movies
sometimes it just
coincidence when a big celebrity winds
up playing a comic-book character the
reason why it was probably okay that
they went with that level of star power
with Batman in 1989 because if you watch
the features and the interviews
surrounding the making of that movie
they say that it was a huge financial
risk for the studio at the time they
shot it in London and it was the most
expensive movie that had ever been made
in London at that time Tim Burton was a
young twentysomething director so he was
also a huge risk for the studio and up
to that point Batman had been defined by
the 1966 campy Adam West TV series so in
that case it made sense to cast that big
of a star like Nicholson and pay him his
dump truck of money it was a very Robert
Downey jr. Avengers situation we haven't
really seen a lot from the Riddler in
the modern incarnations of Batman movies
they didn't use him during the
Christopher Nolan trilogy but there were
rumors that he was going to be cast for
Dark Knight Rises then David Goyer one
of the coasts screenwriters on the Dark
Knight trilogy said that Leonardo
DiCaprio was almost cast as the Riddler
in Dark Knight Rises he said that as
early as the premiere of The Dark Knight
there was talk about who the villain of
the next movie Dark Knight Rises was
going to be because no one hadn't
completely figured that out yet and the
studio really really wanted Leonardo
DiCaprio as the Riddler but obviously
cut to four years later and we wound up
getting Tom Hardy as Bane even if you're
not familiar with Paul Danos work
they're talking about Matt Reeves Batman
movie being based on the long Halloween
story which obviously is a fantastic
story but that story involves a couple
of different big Batman villains most of
the major villains from that have
already been confirmed as appearing
during Matt Reeves movies so he's not
going to be forced to carry all of the
weight of the villains storyline on his
shoulders I was told there was no riddle
you could not solve and yet you've only
put together one guests after another
each one with no more certainty than the
next if your life depended on it and it
does tell me who is holiday talking
about my favorite versions of the
Riddler I would say john glover from
batman the animated series one of my
favorite versions of the character you
remember him is Lionel Luthor from
Smallville he also starred in the
live-action Batman movies as the evil
scientist that gave the uma thurman
version of poison ivy her origin story
Ivy's
you can't talk about the Riddler without
talking about Jim Carrey's version of
the character I think for what that
movie was he did an amazing job with the
character he's one of the few people in
that movie that knew exactly what kind
of movie he was in one of the greatest
Riddler stories about him in the movies
is the story of what happened behind the
scenes between Jim Carrey and Tommy Lee
Jones version of two-face so Jim Carrey
comedic actor was so in love with the
idea of playing this Riddler character
that they had so much fun with it Tommy
Lee Jones on the other hand is this very
serious dramatic actor who's forced to
do this way over-the-top performance
something he was totally not comfortable
with wearing all those prosthetics and
that makeup also something that he had
never really done before everyone
remembers the memes of Tommy Lee Jones
just angrily staring at people Tommy Lee
Jones spent most of that movie making
that face Jim Carrey when they weren't
on camera
it was the Gotham version of The Riddler
more recently I thought he did an okay
job with that character I wasn't the
biggest fan of that series the Arkham
version the Riddler obviously very cool
then you have the classic versions Frank
Gorshin and John Astin from the 1966
Adam West Batman TV series everyone let
me know in the comments though who's
your favorite version of The Riddler so
far either from the animated series from
the movies or from the Arkham games now
talking about the Catwoman casting if
you guys didn't hear the news earlier
this week they confirmed that zoe
kravitz would be playing the Selina Kyle
Catwoman real-life DC Comics Justice
League fun fact her father or her
stepfather is actually Aquaman in the DC
Universe because Jason Momoa married her
mother Lisa Bonet even if you don't
remember you've probably seen some of
her recent films in the last couple of
years her biggest ones being Mad Max
fury road x-men first class and
fantastic beast - even though that movie
was not great and they didn't really do
a good job with that character she is a
good actress
she just needs good material and the
reason why they would cast her over some
of the other actresses she was competing
with is just because she did the best
job and she probably had the best
chemistry with Robert Pattinson 'he's
batman probably one of the most critical
things yes they need to be great at
doing all the action big fight scenes
things like that but her dynamic with
Batman needs to be really really good
because their relationship is really
important during Batman the long
Halloween and obviously if that's going
to be the story of the movie
then it's really important for what this
next trilogy is going to be it's late
it's hot even for June years from now
when people are talking about the
weather they'll say it's hot but it's
not as hot as the night gianni bini got
married hello Selina care to dance Bruce
if you haven't read the long Halloween
the difference between Batman and
Catwoman relationship during that story
as opposed to what's happening now in
the Tom King comics is that it's
relatively early in their lives as those
alter egos so Batman doesn't know that
Selina Kyle is Catwoman and Catwoman
doesn't know that Bruce Wayne is Batman
they start dating each other as Bruce
Wayne and Selina Kyle during the day or
obviously during the evening but then
they also run into each other as their
alter egos when Batman is chasing
Catwoman down at night without them
knowing each other secret identity so
it's a very playful relationship where
they wind up working together to help
solve this holiday murder storyline that
runs through the long Halloween it's not
really clear how much they're gonna
borrow from that comic book story I'm
assuming that they're gonna be changing
some elements so we'll be a copy-paste
situation Anne Hathaway's version of the
character during the Dark Knight Rises a
little more real-world so it's a little
toned down a little more subtle even
during the bigger moments but my
favorite live-action Catwoman so far is
still the Michelle Pfeiffer version from
Batman Returns I just feel like she did
a fantastic job in that movie for what
that was obviously the tone of those
films is very different from the other
Batman films particularly Christopher
Nolan's trilogy and I'm expecting the
Matt Reeves trilogy to do the same thing
where even though it's going for a very
classic noir detective thriller story
the tone will be very different from
other Batman films you've seen so far
yeah I saw her first
Danny DeVito was also fantastic penguin
during that movie speaking of which now
that we know that Jonah Hill is not
going to be in Matt Reeves Batman
trilogy we have to find out who our
penguin is going to be I feel like of
all the villains that are left to cast
hee in two-face are the two that they
have to nail and if they can get those
two characters right in addition to the
people that they cast so far
you actually got a pretty fantastic cast
but everyone post your reactions in the
comments below what do you think of
their new Riddler in their new Catwoman
so far I will do more Batman movie
videos as they confirm more villains
they're not gonna be shooting the movie
till I think early next year but they've
also said that two-face is supposed to
be in the movie as well as Mad Hatter in
Firefly Firefly obviously being one of
the more minor villains really excited
to see who they picked for Mad Hatter
and two-face though I'll name a new
giveaway winner when I post a new DC
video I'm getting ready to post my
non-spoilery Watchmen episode 1 video
that's gonna be a Sunday night show so I
will be doing episode videos and Easter
eggs for that everybody click here for
that new Batman flash crossover teaser
for crisis on Infinite Earths and click
here for my Suicide Squad to first look
breakdown thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]
you